this one's my favorite one it comes from
radio
and it's read what you write out loud
it's the best trick in the book that
anybody can do
anytime all the time when you read as we
were talking about
um music and how the neuroscience of
music works i want you guys to think
about your voice
as a note like a song right because it
is it has a frequency
and when you read text you hear the
voice of the person on the other end
so it's my job as the writer to make
sure that the voice you hear is the one
i want you to hear
the one that's going to make you buy my
stuff or share my message or comment on
my link whatever it is
for me for example i have what i call
resting [ __ ] voice
like when i write so i constantly have
to use a lot of emojis to tamper that
down or to lend some humor
to it one key test you can do is by
reading out loud is thinking about
literally how your mouth feels when you
say words so um
i love this example this is i shop at
west elm
and they sent me this coupon in the mail
and it says
this certificate is issued for reward
purposes and is a duplicate of the
certificate you've received by email
kill me now right so what they're really
saying is like hey dingaling
we sent you a copy of this coupon via
email you can't use both
right but instead duplicate of their
certificate you guys can hear me having
a hard time saying that
and when you slow people down when you
make it harder for them
to get annoyed then they don't trust you
and then they don't want to give you
your money so you want to think about
what's human what's that natural
language
what feels comfortable to you and then
also it's a great way to
catch mistakes because when you read out
loud you get embarrassed quickly
and you're like oh no i want to show you
an example of
that here so i'm writing sales peeps
mold your scripts to your own voice
otherwise you sound fake ass and
untrustworthy plus other tips i learned
from a former life in broadcast radio
page all the way down so
a lot going on here some of the tips we
touched on before i'm
saying mold your scripts into your own
voice so i'm starting this sentence with
a verb i'm commanding people i'm using
my own voice here i say fake ass i'm not
saying everybody can do this but but i
do
i'm having i'm emojiing it so it's clear
that i know
i'm using a word that's a little bit
maybe wild for linkedin
and i'm justifying what i said like
because isn't here but the because it's
implied
right so that again gives me that
authority i've used the
um parentheses for some visual cue that
under the breath thing
and then i love to use the d to do to
keep that ball going so there's a motion
towards
clicking the link